- L'appel didididididididididide
Québec souhaite doter chaque
chambre des maisons des aînés
d'une caméra de surveillance.
Celle-ci sera posée face au lit,
avec la possibilité de pivoter
sur 360°AiAinsi, il sera
possible d'effectuer une tournée
visuelle des chambres
PAUL BRUNET, PDG, Conseil
pour la protection des maleses
- Qui va faire ça? Ça prend du
monde pour surveiller les écrans
pour v- - - - - - - - - - - - -n
des malades s'interroge sur
la pertinence de cette mesure
dans le contexte de pénurie
de travailleurs.eeeeeeeeeeeeeeee
qui est survenu lors du décès
de la èère de Gilles Duceppe.
On avait vu après coup la dame
passer dans les écrans.
à Montréal-Nord à l'heure
du midi ne cachent pas leur
malaise face à l'appel d'offres
de Québec.
- C'esjejejejejejejejejejejejejt
de respecter la vie privée
des gens!
- Non, non, non! Même,
je trouve que ce serait.........
- Le ministre de la Santé,
convaincu de l'initiative
de son gouvernement.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre Santé
et Services sociaux, Québec
- Le premier objectif de tout
ça, c'est la sécurité
des patients. C'est s s s s s s.
PAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON
chchef, Parti québécois
- Je ne comprends pas comment
on peut d'office mettre
"Big Brother".
- Sans s'y opposer formellement,
certains chefs de parti doutent
de l'efficacité de cette mesure.
GABRIEL NADEAU-Débébébébébébébée
- C'est un peu triste qu'on
en soit rendu là et ça ne peut
pas être ça la solution pour
mieux prendre soin des aînés
ÉRIC DUHAIME, chef du PCQ
- S'il y a un constetement,
puis que c'est de façon libre
et volontaire, je n'ai aucune
- Le ministère de la Santé
précise toutefois que
les caméras ne seront pas
activées en tout temps.
FRANCOIS LEGAULT, d d d d d d dc
- Seulement si l'aîné le veuté
ncnc, l'aîné qui n'en veut pas,
de caméra, dans sa chambre,
il n'y en aura pas
- L'Association des CHSLD
privés non conventionnés vtt
pour sa part d'un bon oeil
l'installation de caméras.
PAl'Association des CHSLD privés
- Ça va définitivement aider.
Si l'infirmière n'a pas besoin
physiquement de faire le tour
de 30 000, 40 000 pieds caaiaiaa
tournée visuelle des résidents,
mais elle peut le faire dans
sa chambre, dans 30 secondes,
ça cha
au coût d'environ
2,8 milliards $, devraient
permettre d'héberger, à terme,
près de 3500 personnes âgées.
Ici Hadi Hassinanananananananaa